let's open up the mailbag and we've got
some questions not just
that came through the pft twitter
account but also through the peter king
a football morning in america mailbag
and i love this one for a variety i love
my you love my mail don't you mike yeah
yes i have about zero respect for me
they ripped the living crap out of me
peter that's that's what welcome to the
internet we've we've been dealing with
that ever since we first logged on and
put our names out there but here's this
one peter you need to get off the wacky
weed with your six for one and seven for
one trade ideas great great ideas this
week by the way for the different trades
that could happen regardless of kyle
shanahan's bromance with kirk cousins no
way a sane gm allows the trade to be
made no way the niners should compound
their error for not signing tom brady as
a free agent last march by trading for
cousins this year and you had a great
three-way trade of cousins to the 49ers
jimmy garoppolo to the houston texans
and deshawn watson to the vikings my
reaction to that on monday was peter
don't tease me like that
and and i'll defend you on this one i
think kirk cousins and kyle shannon
would be great together i think shanahan
would love to have kirk cousins i just
don't think the vikings are going to
move kirk cousins because cousins is
going to save mike zimmer's job for
2022.
look here's here's the basic point that
i tried to get across and i should have
said it in these exact words as a matter
of fact i'm answering the question in my
column on monday and what i'm basically
saying is
everybody responds and says that
what do you mean kirk cousins isn't
better than garoppolo i said there's one
factor that none of you are talking
about and that is
kirk cousins has played
95 of the last 96 regular season games
okay jimmy garoppolo has played
25 of the last 48 regular season games
guy who's there half the time
guy who's there all the time which one
would you rather have mike
without question without question i
think i think kirk cousins is in a
higher stratosphere than jimmy garoppolo
when both are healthy and i've been as
critical
of kirk cousins as anyone i think
there's a hard ceiling over what he will
be able to take a team to i don't think
he's going to take a team to a
conference championship i don't think
he's taking a team to a super bowl but
he's better than garoppolo
when it's working for cousins he can
make all the throws he can run that kyle
shanahan offense i think and really to
elaborate on my points everyone
understands where i'm coming from on
cousins i think the vikings understand
that they're not going to find a
suitable replacement for cousins they'll
have a bad year and that's when people
start getting fired they need to get
back to the playoffs this year they've
got that roller coaster in minnesota
where it's one year no playoffs next
year playoffs and that's good enough
apparently for the wealths but they got
to get to the playoffs this year and
they need kirk cousins to do it they're
not going to move kirk cousins uh now i
guess if they could get to sean watson
if you're if your idea would work maybe
maybe they would but i i think i think
shanahan would love to get kirk cousins
if he could
but the only way the vikings are going
to consider it is if they have an
upgrade over kirk cousins and a nice
graphic but that's good i like the
graphic but they're not going to find
one they're just not going to find one
yeah and and look uh i i have my issue
with cousins i think anybody who watches
him consistently will have issues with
him
but the fact is
you know you've got to play somebody at
quarterback who can uh who can have
great games and who you might think geez
you know it would be better to have my
homes
well i i'd be better if i look like brad
pitt
and so
you you have to live you have to live in
the world
that you're in
and let's not all of a sudden
just say that kirk cousins is useless
he's a usable
good to sometimes very good nfl
quarterback
and all i can say is there is value in a
guy being there every week
and kirk cousins is there every week
jimmy garoppolo isn't
by the way speaking of brad pitt for
those of you watching the program on
peacock one of the selections uh from
the the vast movie database burn after
reading brad pitt george clooney francis
mcdormand worth your hour and a half
quick movie great and brad pitt is
excellent in it shameless plug for the
various
uh content available on peacock all
right uncle phil hey
sometimes you ask a question and it
makes it to two different shows we had
it last night on pftpn peter i want your
take on this question from uncle phil
circumstances are different but who
lasts longer in seattle a russell wilson
b pete carroll or c
they're both gone like carson wentz and
doug peterson in the same off-season
i mean that's the hundred thousand
dollar question my guess right now as we
sit here is pete carroll
and as we talked about the first segment
you know i'm not saying that's the right
way to go but i'm saying that it looks
like that's the way they're going to go
that they're going to choose the coach
who turned 70 this year over the
quarterback who is 32 and who has eight
to 10 years left
yeah and i i agree that i think carol is
going to be there longer just because i
feel like this thing has already hit
critical mass the question is when does
the explosion happen this year or next
year i don't think i i if i had to guess
i'd say the over under is next
march 17 or whenever the league year
begins in 2022
fmia reader kevin wursting has a
question about desean watson
if he's worth a ton of draft picks in a
vacuum but then the team that gives up
those picks degrades its overall talent
to the level where houston currently is
what's the point and and that's that's
the be careful what you wish for
side of this for desean watson because
you do get your trade team gives up a
lot to get you and you look around and
you're on a 4-12 roster again
absolutely and that's got to be a
concern of desean watson but
i would look for
i i'd look long term if i'm desean
watson you don't want to get traded to a
team
and then think well you know where am i
going in two years you don't want to do
this you want to make this a permanent
move and that's why
i think a place like carolina makes a
lot of sense even if carolina is at
least partially denuded
of its really good young talent even if
it costs you maybe mccaffrey or or or a
you know one or two other pieces
of that young puzzle i'd really try to
draw the line at brian burns though the
the pass rusher that is a keeper long
term for them but
you you put your faith in a coach
who you believe is gonna be there for
the next five to seven years and who's
got a chance to
build a continuum over a long period of
time and that's why i would believe in
matt rule right now if i were the camp
of desean watson i would think
that matt rules scott fitter the new gm
and especially this owner who is a
desperado who's going to do everything
in his power and get involved and make
sure
that this thing is going in the right
direction i think they have the pieces
in place to build a good team long term
they just don't have a great quarterback
long term
and i guarantee you one thing david
tepper will not do he will not say one
thing to his franchise quarterback and
do something else tepper gets that part
of it it's not that hard to figure out
but tepper wants that franchise
quarterback so badly he's got the coach
he wants the gm he wants and now he
wants that franchise quarterback another
desean watson question peter and we've
we've
kicked this around from time to time but
given where things are right now it's
important to raise it again a red zone
alk asks the question is it the time for
desean watson to speak up he's handled
his business quietly and privately in
contrast to russell wilson who had that
that epic interview with dan patrick
is it time for deshaun watson to say
something about what he wants and why he
wants it
i don't think so mike there's no i i
don't see that much of an upside for him
to speak
today
or
you know
in the next
few weeks let's say
i think time might come
two weeks before the draft let's say
if uh nick casario is still stuck on i'm
not responding to uh to trades or to any
trade offers
but to me right now
you know
his words can die in the wilderness
you know everybody knows what he wants
he wants a trade we all know it
if the texans
become willing to trade him before the
draft then maybe he doesn't have to open
his mouth
and talk about here's why i want to
trade
okay because mike you you have a feeling
don't you that he's got a couple of
things that he's holding back right
that he's got a couple of things he's
holding back
that at the right time he's going to say
them it just doesn't feel like february
26 is the right time it just doesn't
make that much sense to me
if the texans are willing to do this on
their own
i'm going to take those secrets to my
grave
i think that makes a ton of sense you're
right and the fact that he could
ultimately go public with some things
that would further embarrass the team
could be the thing that finally gets
them to do what he wants i mean two
weeks ago they they let jj watt go at a
time when watt was becoming increasingly
salty a little sign of belligerence and
maybe they didn't want to get into a
fight with j.j watt publicly over his
desire to be released so they let him go
once they think that that that may be
coming with deshaun watson maybe they
view it differently peter i just i'm
just perplexed by
i understand
in theory
why you say we just paid this guy a
bunch of money we're not going to trade
him but if he's determined to get out
once they realize he means it i don't
know do they not think he means it once
they realize he means it the question
becomes
when and how are you going to move on
because he's moving on he'll sit out
he'll pay back money uh somebody
explained it perfectly a few weeks ago
he came from nothing even if he has to
pay back a lot of the money he's already
received he's still got plenty more than
he ever dreamed he was going to have
he'll sit he'll wait and it's i'm going
to tell you
i'm going to tell you i'm going to tell
you two things right now that
in the last few days as i've been making
calls about this
one of the things i called someone who
knows deshaun watson very well
and i said okay deshaun watson's made
27.1 million dollars or 28.1 million uh
is since september okay here's a guy
who's never had real money in his life
you know he comes from
very modest means
and
you know he is a guy
who basically has never really had much
until just right now so if you were to
tell desean watson okay listen your
salary this year it's like 10 million
and if you sit out
and sit out all of training camp and
take the fines which can't be rescinded
that's another 2.4 million i think it is
so if you do all that if you do all that
you know it's going to cost you
let's say 10.3 million dollars
you know are you or 13 million i'm sorry
are you willing to do that
i this person who i asked said deshaun
watson wouldn't even think twice about
it he would say of course i'm willing to
do that
even though
even though
this is monumental money
it's more about
starting somewhere else in deshaun
watson's mind right now
two other factors to consider when we do
that math one
if he sits out the whole year he owes
another 5.4 million back to the team in
unearned signing bonus money now now it
gets complicated he'd get that back if
he comes back next year
and see if he'd sit out a whole year and
they never give in which i'd i'd be
stunned beyond stunned if it got to that
point where he would cave after a year
and come back but if he does come back
in a year his contract's been told his
salary next year becomes 10 million the
same 10 million he was going to make
this year it's current it's currently
due to be 35 million
in 2022 so on top of everything you lose
now
when you come back if you finally
just say uncle oh you win texans you've
you've beaten me down you've proven to
me that you're not going to let me go
and i'm coming back you're out 25
million on the back end because you're
waiting another year to get to your 35
million now event you know you keep
playing you could argue well sitting out
a year he can extend his career a year
and you know maybe you make all that
money back and then some
but uh this gets very expensive for
deshaun watson but no matter how
expensive it is peter you're right he
doesn't care
and that's what stuns me about the
texans position because
unless they believe at some unless
they're just willing to let him sit
forever
like mike brown was with carson palmer
unless they're willing to do that and
brown eventually traded him when two
first round picks landed in his lap but
unless they're willing to let him sit
out forever i don't know what the end
game is for the texans
the end game basically is to do
everything humanly possible
to try to fix this to try to mend this
and fire jack easter be that would fix
it that would i don't know that that
would even matter at this point i don't
think it would happen i once you know a
few weeks ago i asked jimmy johnson we
were going over this
and one of the things that jimmy johnson
said to me it was he was kind of
chuckling when he said this
i said well here are the problems you
know jack easter e blah blah blah and he
says jack easterbee he said i'd call
deshaun watson tomorrow and basically
say okay we just fired jack easter
you know i mean
because that's the way jimmy thinks
that's the way jimmy thinks it go that's
almost like in the in the uh
you know that any logical
business bottom line businessman would
think
okay so
but but i think
mike that this the only way this has a
chance
literally the only way this has a chance
is for cal mcnair to sit down with
deshaun watson
and if i were deshaun watson i would
actually want that
because
i would want to say
to to cal mcnair cal listen
i'm never going to trust you
it doesn't matter what you say to me
here right now how we try to fix things
whatever i'm not going to trust you now
i don't know that desean watson would
say that
but you know if he did i think that
would go a long way toward facilitating
this trade
but
i would still want if i'm cal mcnair i'd
want to look my franchise quarterback in
the face
and probably you would too mike and just
say
i made a mistake and i want to fix this
i wanna
talk about how we can fix it
listen if i owned an nfl team i would
screw things up in many many ways but i
can guarantee you i would never say
something to one of my players and not
live up to it or i would not create the
accidental impression that i had made a
promise that i had failed to deliver
communication is the key and delivering
on your promises is critical in any
business
no manager is is worth a damn if he or
she isn't willing to make simple direct
messages and honor the things that were
said and not do something else that's
where this went off the rails and that's
why firing jack eastwood wouldn't be the
answer because if i'm desean watson and
they say we fire jack eastwood it's like
fine but you know what it's just a
matter of time before there's another
jack easter b because the guy who's
making the hires is is not making the
right hires at the upper levels of the
organization
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports